Traduttore: Sebastiano Inama
Revisore: Federico Sangati
Ma veramente non sono io
il protagonista di questo talk.
"So ladies and gentlemen,
let me introduce..."
Caballero!
Ecco, per tutti quelli che in sala
che hanno dai 40 ai 50 anni
e sono appassionati di moto,
io potrei finire il talk qui,
perché questo è un oggetto
che parla da solo.
Per tutti gli altri,
volevo raccontarvi qualcosa.
Questa moto negli anni '70
è stata l'oggetto del desiderio
di una marea di ragazzini.
Se tu avevi il Caballero
le ragazzine ti correvano dietro,
Questo era il livello
a cui eravamo con questa moto.
È stato un modello di tale successo
che l'azienda che lo produceva
ha avuto una crescita
impressionante delle vendite,
tale che alla fine degli anni '70 era
il terzo gruppo motociclistico europeo.
Negli anni '80 l'azienda si è superata
è ha vinto di tutto:
tre campionati mondiali di trial,
i campionati nazionali fuoristrada,
vinceva in qualsiasi categoria.
Ma facciamo un fermo immagine,
entriamo nella macchina del tempo,
riavvolgiamo il nastro fino agli anni '90.
L'avrete capito,
sono un appassionato di moto.
E quale maggior fortuna
per un appassionato di moto
di andare a lavorare
per una fabbrica che fa moto?
È quello che mi è successo nel 1991.
Non in quella fabbrica, ma in un'altra.
Sono entrato che fatturava 60 milioni,
15 anni dopo ne fatturava 630.
Immaginate cosa significhi all'interno
di un'azienda che cresce 10 volte.
È come essere in una lavatrice
che non si ferma mai.
E cresce, e la roba da fare
è sempre di più di ciò che riesci a fare,
però con la fiducia nel team,
con la voglia di fare ci si riesce.
Ci sono i momenti di depressione,
ci sono i momenti di gioia delirante.
Cosa resta dopo 15 anni
di un'esperienza così esaltante?
Beh, due cose.
Da una parte,
una grande esperienza di dominio,
una grande esperienza di settore,
e dall'altra parte
delle amicizie indissolubili,
ben oltre l'essere semplicemente colleghi.
Entriamo di nuovo nella macchina del tempo
e riemergiamo nel 2014, ad aprile.
Uno di questi amici indissolubili,
Mariano, mi telefona e mi dice:
"Senti, che ne dici di fare
una cena a base di asparagi?"
Cena, asparagi, amici.
Sicuramente non si rifiuta.
E giù a capofitto a mangiare asparagi.
A un certo punto, nel mezzo
di questa rimpatriata
tra amici ed ex colleghi,
Mariano, con un tono un po' formale dice:
"Ragazzi, ve lo ricordate il Caballero?"
"Bellissimo! Il mito della nostra giovinezza!"
Ok, stop. La fabbrica che lo produce
se la sta passando veramente male.
Sono rimasti 6 dipendenti,
fanno meno di un milione di fatturato,
sono 3 anni che sono in perdita.
Non sarei stupito se tra due mesi,
due settimane, arrivasse la notizia
che è saltata o la chiudono,
oppure viene acquistata
da una multinazionale
che prende il marchio Caballero
e lo butta in un cassetto polveroso
assieme a tanti altri marchi.
A quel punto
ci è passato un brivido lungo la schiena.
Al tavolo eravamo 5 persone
con più di 100 anni
di esperienza motociclistica
accumulata sulle spalle.
Vogliamo lasciare
che il destino faccia il suo corso,
o vogliamo mettere la firma sul più grande
piano di rilancio motociclistico europeo?
Vabbè avete capito: 5 minuti dopo
eravamo pancia a terra a creare un piano.
Il piano prevedeva
tre pilastri fondamentali:
il primo, continuare a fare
quello che la fabbrica già faceva,
quindi migliorare la rete di vendita
e il prodotto sulle moto da fuoristrada;
il secondo pilastro del rilancio,
rivitalizzare completamenteil Caballero.
Un po' l'operazione che Fiat
ha fatto con la 500,
o che BMW ha fatto con la Mini,
quindi rimanere su un guscio classico
e metterci dentro tanta tecnologia;
e il terzo, che non poteva che essere
la mobilità elettrica,
cominciando dalle bici elettriche
da fuoristrada, le mountain bike,
che era un po' il nostro DNA,
per poi passare alle bici da città
a pedalata assistita,
e alla vera mobilità elettrica.
Bene. Abbiamo un team,
abbiamo un progetto: è fatta.
Quasi, intanto mancano i soldi.
Che si fa? Non ci perdiamo mica d'animo!
Prepariamo una bella presentazione,
tipo startuppers,
e individuiamo dei possibili investitori,
ossia degli imprenditori
che consideravamo potenziali investitori
nel nostro progetto.
Li incontriamo e sono persone come noi,
hanno più o meno la nostra età.
Erano stati in qualche modo colpiti
dal vento tiepido del Caballero,
alcuni di loro lo avevano avuto.
Cominciamo la nostra presentazione,
e vediamo l'occhio lucido, la lacrimuccia.
Ecco, il gioco è fatto!
E infatti ci sono cascati.
No, cascati è una brutta parola.
Ci hanno creduto!
Hanno creduto nel nostro sogno,
ci hanno dato fiducia, hanno investito,
e così è partita la nostra avventura.
Era l'8 novembre 2014.
Dentro abbiamo trovato sei persone
che avevano il marchio Caballero
stampato a fuoco sul cuore,
cinque pazzi che saltano a bordo,
un milione di fatturato, un piano,
e tutto sommato anche delle finanze
che bastavano per rilanciare
e per mettere in pratica il nostro piano.
Bene.
1, 2, 3: si parte.
Cominciamo a darci da fare,
questo è quello che abbiamo trovato.
Il 15 luglio 2015
lanciamo le prime due bici,
poi rinnoviamo la gamma moto
e ampliamo la rete distributiva.
Il mercato ci dà fiducia,
e in quell'anno fatturiamo 5 milioni.
I conti sono quasi in pareggio.
A questo punto il mercato
ci sta dando fiducia,
e vai col 2016 a ritmo spaventoso.
E facendo cosa?
Ampliando di nuovo la gamma
delle bici elettriche e cominciando
a concepire il nuovo Caballero.
Lo presentiamo nella fiera più importante
che è a Milano, a novembre 2016.
Nel nostro piccolo è un trionfo.
800.000 visitatori ci votano
come la seconda moto più bella del salone.
Wow, incredibile!
Siamo assolutamente alle stelle!
Chiudiamo l'anno a 10 milioni,
con i clienti che ci dicono questo,
quindi rinnovo della fiducia,
anche in modo molto materiale,
e iniziamo un 2017 ancora più potente.
Ora dobbiamo ingegnerizzare il Caballero
perché se è piaciuto, a questo punto
dobbiamo renderlo costruibile e
metterlo in produzione, e ci siamo quasi.
Nel senso che lunedì
comincerà il montaggio del primo lotto.
Poi, ovviamente, dopo aver incrementato
per uno o due anni la conoscenza
del mercato delle bici elettriche
tiriamo fuori il nostro gioiellino.
Vi chiedo un applauso
per il nostro giocattolino.
Io sono commosso.
Come un papà fuori dalla sala parto
che vede arrivare il bambino.
Sono particolarmente commosso
perché lui che ci ha aiutato
a tirare fuori la bici prima ha detto:
"Porca miseria! Ma è talmente bella
che non sembra neanche vera!"
Giuro che è vera, la stiamo vendendo
e c'è anche qualcuno che la compra,
o sarebbe un ologramma
finanziario senza precedenti.
In ogni curva di questa bici
c'è quantità di sudore infinita.
E qui, da rapid followers siamo diventati
quelli che vogliono dire qualcosa
nel mercato delle bici elettriche.
"Handling grip and mileage"
è il nostro motto.
Le ruote sono diverse:
quella dietro, piccola e cicciotella,
quella davanti,
un po’ più grande e agile,
per avere grip e stabilità sul terreno,
ma anche l'agilità di superare ostacoli.
La batteria integrata
è la più grande del mercato,
per stufarsi di andare in bici
prima che lampeggi la famosa ultima spia,
che dà sempre ansia.
Quando dici: "Non ce la faccio più",
però neanche la bici,
quindi siamo fritti e si torna a piedi.
Troppo gentili, è lei che se lo merita.
Anche quest’anno finisce molto bene.
Probabilmente faremo 15...
Non c'è il numero,
non vorrei che fosse...
Eccolo!
No è che... I gatti neri...
Faremo 15 milioni di fatturato.
Siamo carichi come delle molle,
perché stiamo cominciando
a vendere il Caballero adesso.
Tra parentesi, la settimana scorsa
vari sondaggi ci hanno messo
tra il primo e quarto posto delle moto
più belle presentate quest'anno
quindi è un successo incredibile.
Questa sembra piacere,
abbiamo una quantità di ordini
che speriamo di riuscire a rispettare.
Carichi come delle molle
per fare 25 milioni di fatturato,
e poi sogniamo anche di farne 40.
Sono stanco solo a raccontarla la storia,
non vi dico l'energia spesa per farla.
A questo punto mi viene da dire
che finora sembra una storia di successo,
poi vedremo.
Dietro però c'è stato un piano e
c'è anche un team e magari anche bravino,
e sarei stupido a non dirlo.
Però le ragioni del successo
sono più profonde,
e sono le ragioni del FARE.
E guarda caso sono declinate esattamente
come le ha declinate TEDx Trento.
Per questo quando ho visto il bando
ho scritto immediatamente:
"Non potete non prendermi!"
La F di fare è certamente fiducia,
perché è fiducia nell'idea,
bisogna credere in qualcosa.
È fiducia nel team.
Noi ce la faremo anche quando
saremo un attimino depressi.
E mia moglie che è qui
sa cosa vuol dire questo.
Instillare fiducia negli investitori.
perché devono credere in voi.
Ecco, se c'è la fiducia
passa via la stanchezza.
Non c'è età che tenga.
Nella nostra carta d'identità
c'è scritto: data di nascita, 1955-1959,
ma è sicuramente un errore di stampa.
Cioè, noi abbiamo vent'anni!
Non c'è modo di convincerci
di qualcosa di diverso.
Il secondo ingrediente fondamentale
è quello dell'Agire.
Nulla accade senza sensazione.
I sogni nel cassetto
fanno semplicemente la muffa.
I sogni devono nascere dalla testa,
trasformarsi in pensiero,
diventare un piano
passare attraverso il sudore,
e forse alla fine la vostra idea
diventerà un qualcosa di reale.
Però bisogna fare questo sforzo,
altrimenti non succede nulla.
Se continuiamo a ripetere le stesse azioni
i risultati saranno sempre gli stessi.
Solo nelle pubblicità
le cose cambiano da sole.
L'altro punto è quello del rischio:
non si può pensare di fare qualcosa
rimanendo della propria comfort zone.
Io sono tranquillo, sto lì seduto
e le cose mi succedono.
Anche questo solo nelle pubblicità,
mai vista una roba del genere.
Bisogna prendere dei rischi,
misurati, ma prenderseli.
Bisogna andare fuori
nel mondo, e correre.
E poi arriviamo alla E.
La E è bisvalida, come le figurine.
Per prima cosa ci vuole
un entusiasmo incrollabile,
indistruttibile per esplorare, sempre.
Perché esplorare non è andare in giro
con una cartina e cercare il sentiero.
No, esplorare è vedere un bosco
e dire:
"Secondo me li ci sarà un sentiero".
Significa percorrerlo,
e dopo tre volte che lo percorri
si comincia a vedere il sentiero.
Qualcun'altro ti segue,
diventa una mulattiera,
poi altra gente ti segue
e allora diventa una strada
e poi lo chiamano mainstream.
Alla faccia del mainstream,
prima era un bosco e basta!
Quindi bisogna darsi da fare.
Quello che vi ho raccontato adesso
è la nostra storia,
il nostro sogno.
Ma qual è la vostra storia?
Quali sono i vostri sogni?
Noi esseri umani
quando vogliamo qualcosa caparbiamente
siamo sicuramente capaci di fare,
di raggiungere degli obiettivi
che razionalmente
non sembrano raggiungibili.
Ecco io vi auguro di essere
su questo palco del TEDx,
o da qualche altra parte
a raccontare le vostre storie
tra due mesi, due anni.
State sicuri che io sono da qualche parte
nascosto, in streaming ad ascoltarvi,
orgoglioso magari di avervi dato
la piccola spallatina finale
per forzarvi a fare qualcosa.
Quindi FATE, e a questo punto
auguro buone storie a tutti.
(Applausi)